okay so what the reason why when
somebody calls somebody average that's
usually perceived to be an insult right
I think we hear it that way we give it
that way nobody's ever told somebody
that there's ever their average is like
a nice thing to say to somebody now we
can say that like oh well average is
most people are average kind of but also
not really right if you look at like an
average person like an average person
has 1.9 legs because some people are
missing legs but no human has 1.9 legs
we have two or one right when we look at
who we are as people there are some
things that we excel at and there are
some things that we don't do anything at
so I think that's why we never feel
average right because we're above
average hopefully at whatever our
competency is in So when you say that
somebody's average is always going to be
perceived as an insult so I'm sure that
uh Camilla or anybody else you guys all
had crazy degree you guys are all more
educated than I am right I'm sure that
on a whole you might be an average
person but you're not going to perceive
yourself that way because you push
yourself forward in some areas that make
you not average and hopefully you're
looking for other people to plug into
that those uh above average
I just want to say it's not about even
my degree you know it's not about my
Masters it's about what I've overcome
and achieved in this life that makes me
a Survivor and above average I have been
homeless on the street and I'm sitting
here today and not representing that my
struggle My Success makes me above
average and nobody can't tell me that
I'm not because if that's what I need to
tell myself to get up in the morning and
do my [__] that's what's gonna have to
happen okay
hold on
Bros
you disrespecting me so I've got a
reason don't talk to me like that bro
stop stop stop stop I just told you to
stop I just start I just told you to
stop talking guys I was gonna you a
chance but you can't you can't come on
Wow 30 30 seconds go well 30 seconds and
then you
anyway I can't remember she just threw
me up okay remember okay
um it was just so funny
okay okay like I don't know what's going
on
okay
guys
guys guys guys now listen listen listen
listen guys guys
guys guys guys guys guys
yo yo yo all right all right guys okay
okay all right thank you the first rule
of the podcast don't interrupt the horse
there we're not gonna tolerate that no
more if that happens you gotta go thank
you
yeah are we all cool with that okay all
right cool thank you I know I know
disrespectful stuff either thank you
okay wait wait
okay no no no no no stop
stop um we're gonna go on to the next
question all right so I'm gonna leave
okay
this might be your platform but respect
okay okay goodbye go go go okay because
[Music]
don't call me bro
bro
I know do you know something right do
you know something right excuse me
excuse me excuse me what's your name
hello young lady what's your name T do
you know what I'm gonna do for the first
time ever I'm gonna [__] follow you
see you later
okay okay look at look at look at your
your your issue your issue stop you're
doing it again okay oh my God
oh
my God
you're lucky we're in there I'll smoke
you myself
[Music]
what
yeah you sound right well teach you a
lesson next time
[Music]
bro
let's go
[Music]
get out get out get out get out get out
come on
[__] how many bodies you got [__] oh my
God get out get out
get get the [__] up get the [__] out of
my apartment get out oh my God
okay hold on can I just for my own
safety who are we allowed to call her
out here and who are we not allowed to
call bro I just want to know get the
[__] out lock the door lock the other
side too blessing lock the phone
yeah the only reason was because she
kept interrupting me Jesus Christ
look it I don't oh my God
what can you go check just go go double
check go
no but okay
look at the difference that has never
had I've never had anyone walk over
kicked out I think best as we move on
quick coffee goodbye okay
good difference yeah but she's saying I
was disrespectful to her how
yeah okay okay
you kept going okay guys guys guys guys
guys guys guys okay
she's gonna be like waiting outside
you know what's crazy
tonight and it didn't I was like
nah that's scary I'm sorry I'm I was
scared yeah the only reason I was gonna
let her talk is the crazy thing but she
kept interrupting me and I was just like
if you're gonna keep interrupting me you
have to go like I don't
I don't know if she could hear you
honestly and you didn't call her name as
well no shake it shaking here she could
she just kept it no she I give up wow
students saying Esther is the same one
in this podcast
okay um I can't believe Auntie Jenny was
worse than me just saying okay hold on
we shouldn't shut down anybody
okay I didn't think anyone was that
crazy until she started yeah okay my
next question
I actually didn't think it was that bad
but I guess I just want to know why
she's so mad that cool or broke when I
cool everyone broke it's like it's just
a respect thing it's like your elders
like I just would never I don't know
yeah yeah it's just like I I just
wouldn't call people that but I don't
think
I don't think you meant it like that no
I I think they were already upset and
then him saying bro was just like a
Timber but if they were cool and they
were calling each other bro I think they
would agree there it doesn't matter
and I think it's because you kept
antagonizing the situation how she was
like don't call me bro you're like all
right bro yeah
kid
the vernacular that's just how I speak
in it like so I'm leaving thinking like
oh yeah I'm trying to push her buttons
like all my thing was is that let me say
something because at this point I've
said the least out of everybody do you
get what I'm saying so I was just trying
he said the most yeah
yeah but she wasn't the one talking at
that moment at that moment as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible